Burma's leaders defending her government
this morning against charges of ethnic
cleansing for the first time Nobel Peace
Prize winner Ansan Suchi addressed her
country over accusations that the
military burned down hundreds of low
hinge of Muslim villages more than
400,000 Muslims that fled the
predominantly Buddhist country also
known as Myanmar Jonah Fischer with our
partners at the BBC is in Burma's
capital there was one particular moment
that struck me in this speech by Aung
San su Chi it was when she said that she
really wanted to know why hundreds of
thousands of rehén jure muslims had fled
across the border into bangladesh lots
of those refugees have been speaking to
journalists they're explaining that
they've been leaving because of a
military offensive by the Burmese
government there's two ways of looking
at the way Masucci spoke about this
particular issue the first is that she's
simply out of touch she's not getting
good information here in the capital
nape adorn the second is that she's
being willfully blind to the the alleged
abuses of the Burmese military that it's
too difficult for her politically to say
anything that might be seen as critical
of the Burmese military because she has
to share power with them they were a
very delicate balance between the
civilian government in the Burmese army
here in Myanmar and she doesn't want to
say anything that might might jeopardize
that fragile relationship Norah really
interesting Jonah Fisher and Myanmar
thank you so much